this spectacular home built atop a
waterfall in a Pennsylvania forest is
now on equal footing with the Taj Mahal
the Great Wall of China and the Pyramids
of Giza at least in the eyes of the UN
falling water was designed by famed
American architect Frank Lloyd Wright
and this week falling water and seven
other right buildings were added to the
UNESCO World Heritage List sites that
are singled out for their value to
humanity he is one of America's first
great cultural exports and so this this
inscription on the World Heritage List
is really a recognition of that seminal
contribution that Wright made simply put
our buildings our world our homes even
our landscapes our cities might not be
the same without Frank Lloyd Wright's
work in addition to falling water the
other sites to make the list include
unity temple in Oak Park Illinois
designed by Wright in 1905 and still in
use today it's a beautiful example from
his early period of how he could take an
industrial material structural concrete
and render a sacred space with it and
two of Wright's personal homes Taliesin
built in Wisconsin using native
materials and Taliesin West in
Scottsdale Arizona a structure that
seamlessly blends into its desert
setting these might be the most personal
expressions of his work because he
wasn't setting out to meet the
requirements of a client in fact as his
own homes they also served as his
studios as the place where he would
educate apprentices the other sites
include la's hollyhock house Madison
Wisconsin's Herbert and Catherine Jacobs
house and intentionally low cost
residents built during the Great
Depression and Chicago's Frederick C
Roby house and perhaps Wright's most
well known building New York's
revolutionary Guggenheim Museum designed
by Wright in 1943 and finished in 90
59 six months after his death when we
look at buildings that were built a
hundred years ago or even a shorter time
you know we tend to think of those
buildings as maybe less important than
they actually are so this I think will
help the cause of preserve and not only
these eight buildings and the rest of
Frank Lloyd Wright's work but a lot of
other buildings that are part of our
modern cultural heritage simply gorgeous
yeah I live there modern and just he was
so ahead of his time oh go on with your
bad self
Frank Lloyd Wright